hey youtubers its charlie I just hit a
hundred thousand subscribers and oh my
god what the I just wanted to make
a video to thank all you guys for being
so awesome
I thought about drinking a hundred beers
in your honor but then probably slap
myself maybe just ordering some takeout
and watching some arrow would be more
appropriate almost a year ago I started
making videos to find other people to
talk about all my favorite things with
and as you can see it's gotten a little
out of hand in the best possible way
seriously you should see my coffee bill
though it's pretty bad
so while I may have turned into a bit of
a vampire this has changed my life in
the best possible way and I have all of
you guys to thank for it when people ask
me how to become a youtuber I just say
talk about things that you're really
passionate about find other people that
also enjoy those things and then there's
something that they're really passionate
about that they want to talk about make
a video about it and boom you are a
youtuber whether you're new subscriber
or you drink the kool-aid a long time
ago you may have noticed that things
change week to week that's just me
listening to your guys feedback trying
to make things better that's where
things like the weekly Sherlock and all
the ask emergency Q&A videos and anime
club come from the next big thing I'm
working on is movie night
the funny thing being that movie night
is technically every night even though
that video will only be one day a week
so this movie night is born a lot of you
guys have been asking for video game
videos you know book reviews and a lot
of other things too I love getting your
guys suggestions thank you so much
please keep sending them to me generally
I don't have regrets but I am sorry I
can't answer everyone's comments all the
time
I do read everything though but I have
cranked up the language filters just a
little bit on my comments just to reduce
the f-bomb related deaths on the channel
so if you make a comment and you don't
see it on a video don't worry I still
see it on the back end I really hope you
guys have been enjoying the giveaways
I've been doing lately as part of anime
club and the upcoming weekly giveaway
that I'm gonna do as part of Walking
Dead I might change it a little bit I
really like doing giveaways more than I
like doing contests because it's really
just a way for me to give back to you
guys a lot of you guys have been asking
about t-shirts and other swag I don't
have anything planned yet but I am
working on getting some new channel art
you know making a little bit shinier so
once that happens I might think about
making t-shirts I have been getting some
questions about local meetups and in
real-life events I'm really excited to
do stuff like that I'm not quite ready
yet I'm in the middle of moving Baker
Street to a new location I'm looking for
a new apartment right now so maybe after
that but I will be at VidCon this summer
giving away free stuff
thank you so much you guys for being so
awesome I never thought this would
happen but I am so glad that it did I am
making
channel update video later this week
maybe Thursday or Friday so look out for
that that'll explain what my upload
schedule is going to be through February
and March just because Walking Dead's
coming back and Hannibal season 2 is
coming up right now click here to see my
reactions to Peter Capaldi's new Doctor
Who costume tumblr had a lot of fun with
that one and click here to get my series
8 predictions thank you so much for
watching you guys
now everybody group high five